best head inland traveler far as you can
manage it is only a matter of time
before the I suppose it is but we were
driven from the keep long before that
it's no natural help your strong swimmer
should be a better class of criminal in
this town but now I get to deal with the
flame surprised you could count that
high
here this is the place see that eight
guide us
you
you
we maybe I had enough date yes I lost my
chasm
there's the secret door give me a moment
to open the seal
are you alright
Han how did you never mind get me out of
these chains I'll see to her bones Cass
I need you to tell us I have a
suggestion for our next move
han your planet insane I love it
where do we start we know you have to
run was it Han Cass even if we stop the
storm stow it pan I'm as much to blame
for this as you I'm not leaving you to
fix it yourself okay turning a blade on
your own there's no way to avoid it
they stopped being my own the moment
they mutiny
not now can't you see I'm busy torturing
this high health don't burn the
expensive houses until all the plunder
has been removed
right what you can before we sail
valuables in that file throw the rest in
the fire
[Applause]
Ultima magic far nothing watch
[Music]
too late ridership nothing left to do
but seek with arrested
[Music]
you
you
the gates are part the locking
mechanisms are controlled from those two
towers you know
the wind blows Rotom dammit I didn't see
him skip that does it should meet
costera at the gate
[Music]
[Music]
this is it cus just don't try to talk me
out of this pan
you remember alvars they were the only
thing that kept us mood through that
miserable storm let's do it again how
often are we going to see a tempest like
this in one lifetime
you only were the romantic
shouldn't the storm be growing weaker I
said it probably wouldn't get any
stronger damn him
keep fighting one of us has to make it
your reinforcements they're here they
see me with you
castor oh wait
it ends like it began the two of us
adrift among the wreckage of our lives
but alive and together fortune smiles
with the sharks that look on her face I
love him for some reason pan won't I
love you pan but we can't go on like
this
I know kiss what will happen when I'm
gone
I pick up the pieces or I find myself in
irons I'm sorry for everything I'm not
the span between us maybe as far as the
Sun and the sea but you'll never be far
from my thoughts the Sun and the sea
were never so lucky as to have crossed
paths
I don't expect
when panel I'm not one to commend
recklessness that I suppose we all owe
you a debt of gratitude I don't know
what's more troubling but I'll note your
remark
you've had a long day see to your troops
and get some rest
I'm honored by your consideration